episode 2 of Jiu Jitsu Kaizen season 2
begins with goju and ghetto defeating
all of the terrorists who were trying to
kill Rico Omani following this Gojo
wants to take Riku back to jiu jitsu
high so that she can finally merge with
tengen but instead she asks that they
take her back to her own school so that
she can see her friends for the last
time however not long after arriving
there they're ambushed by a bunch of
different assassins including this guy
who gets destroyed by ghetto and this
other guy who has a curse technique that
enables him to clone himself both of
these assassins were hired by toji
fushiguro who's offering 30 million to
anyone who can kill Rico in reality
though toji doesn't expect these
assassins to beat Gojo but what he wants
is for them to Tire him out so that
later on when Gojo was exhausted toji
himself can swoop in and finish the job
anyway during the fight a young goto
tries to use curse technique reversal
red but at this stage in the timeline he
isn't able to do it since he hasn't
awakened that power yet episode 2 then
ends with Rico's Butler and close
personal friend being kidnapped by an
unknown person